[Music]
well I mean there are just on that I
mean there I think we'd agree that some
of the use of freedom of speech by the
far-right in this country is foreign and
yet they are they argue that they are
challenging the establishment so that
kind of calls into question your
distinction between that but in the
issue of anonymity I tend to take a more
balanced view on it not because I don't
think that transparency is a vital part
of democracy and I think because what
when you have freedom of speech you also
must be accountable and responsible for
the arguments you put out that's how you
have a good debate however I do think we
can't toss aside the fact that in
certain situations anonymity and having
a private space which exists in the real
world is important online and to take an
example and usually I spend my time
criticizing aspects of the hashtag me to
movement but it was a vital part of that
was about women and men being able to
anonymously share their stories as part
of a wider conversation and I think if
you'd privately asked any of those
persons who did it and honestly whether
or not they'd actually speak if they had
to have a verified name on it they'd say
no and so then does that mean that we're
not allowing for a kind of free
discourse so I think with this I'm not
balanced on freedom of speech I think
that should be an absolute but on
anonymity I think we have to have a bit
more of a nuanced discussion I really
made me to role was the naming yeah it
was really what was essential that
suddenly said hey is that person is that
person is that person yeah but some of
those accusations turned out to be not
true so that's why your own amici is a
complex but that's again where freedom
of expression shall come with
responsibility you can also be charged
if you accuse somebody wrongly which is
right because this shouldn't happen so
I'm hearing some themes here on the one
hand of privacy and anonymity being a
really important part of privacy and we
want to have privacy because the
opposite of this is a full surveillance
state which I'm not journey of us
necessarily want to live in either but
then there's this question of if we want
to be free which we also wants we want
to be private we want to be free we need
to have a digital identity we need to
have transparency
we need to have accountability so we've
got a big circle to square here yes man
I want to make sure that you have time
for two so if you've got any point from
this little I just think it's not again
we have to be careful that we're talking
about this country I'm assuming we're
talking about this country or Europe
okay and we have checks and balances and
we have rules and the thing with
anonymity I can never say this word
properly is that it is the domain of the
cowards they it is the most cowardly
thing they do is that they say all this
stuff and they whip up all this hatred
but they haven't the courage to say who
they are and how can you respect people
who create whip up real hatred against
people like me or Diane or whatever and
aren't prepared to expose them so unlike
Mary beard who's much nicer than I am I
have met these guys and I've not made
them my friends but I have said to them
that you disgust me because you're
cowards
I met them because they actually
resorted to some very dangerous threats
and the police actually identified them
and you know when you meet them they are
quite pathetic they're quite pathetic
and unable to defend what they said and
that's what really gets me that under
the guise of
oh this is a free brave new world they
are actually doing nothing useful for
themselves or anybody else having strong
opinions hey I have friends who are even
Tories I don't mind them yeah but but
there is a kind of respect I give them
because they have integrity and there
they can argue their case but what do
you do to people who are threatening to
kill you and cut off your clitoris
because they don't agree with what you
said on the paper review what do you say
to them that there are heroes of freedom
of speech ah for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institutes of arson ideas at IAI TV
you